c'est l'acteur 1 du plan de relance
régional d'ile-de-france premiers axes
de ce programme l'économie avec des
aides aux entreprises et la lutte contre
le chômage une enveloppe de 870 millions
d'euros 500 millions d'euros vont être
consacrés aux prêts et aux fonds de
soutien aux tpe pme commerçants et
indépendants en difficulté les filières
francilienne stratégie comme
l'agriculture l'automobile
l'aéronautique ou la construction vont
être soutenus à hauteur de 75 millions
d'euros
tout comme la culture et le tourisme la
lutte contre le chômage passera par de
nouvelles places de formation attribués
aux demandeurs d'emploi dans les
secteurs en tension
le financement des formations
individuelles sera renforcée deuxième
axe est la solidarité et l'éducation 97
millions d'euros consacrés au pouvoir
d'achat des lycéens et des plus
vulnérables
la région s'est engagée aussi à
organiser des campus d'été
le principe ouvrir les lycées durant les
deux dernières semaines du mois d'août
pour une remise à niveau des fonds sont
aussi débloqués pour les familles
défavorisées pour la période estivale 50
millions d'euros seront consacrés au
secteur de la santé avec notamment 18
mille étudiants infirmiers et aides
soignants rémunérés pour leurs activités
pendant la crise enfin la relance passe
aussi par la transition environnementale
238 millions d'euros consacrés à un
budget participatif environnementale
destinés à des projets publics ou encore
au développement de transports
écologiques et au rer vélo puis le
déploiement de bornes publiques de
recharge